[Musique]
au sommet d'une montagne lointaine une
belle jeune femme use de ses talents de
pâtissière de sculptrice et de
couturière pour élaborer des douceurs
alléchante elle a l'art de révéler la
beauté ténébreuse de chacune de ses
oeuvres qu'elles partagent ensuite avec
nous les créatures monstrueuses kalapo
publie sous son toit
je ne sais plus à quand remonte votre
dernière au pas normal tu appelle ça un
repas normal c'est spectaculaire manque
de sucre quand elle aura refroidi
j'ai sculpteur est un visage
je me sers d'une poche remplie de
glaçage au je vois je peux t'aider
on
une jolie petite princesse ne m'attend
pas
c'est notre maison toutes les créatures
étranges et inhabituelles sont les
bienvenus et en sécurité
rejoignez nous dans l'univers
délicieusement macabre des curieuses
création de christine mcconnell
je pense qu'il faut l'étouffer reconnaît
bien là de gentillesse ça prend beaucoup
trop de temps
[Applaudissements]
il ya des moments dans la vie d'une
rockstar qui définissent qu'il est là où
il n'y avait que l'obscurité
maintenant il y à toi
[Musique]
et ça va secouer
la nuit d'halloween 1963 à haddonfield
dans l'illinois
michael myers alors âgée de 6 ans
assassiné de sang-froid sa propre soeur
mais ce n'est que 15 ans plus tard lors
de la nuit d'halloween 1978 que la
légende de michael myers est née après
s'être échappé de l'hôpital
psychiatrique
il est retourné à haddonfield
où il a sauvagement assassiné des
résidents de son quartier seule la jeune
laurie strode avait survécu
alors laurie
après toutes ces années
qu'est ce qui selon vous a poussé
michael à commettre tous ses moeurs
[Musique]
vous croyez pas aux crocs bethel non
vous devriez dans cette ville michael
myers est un mythe une histoire pour
effrayer les enfants c'est quoi mais ce
croque mitaine x
et il est retour michael myers s'est
échappé ces quatre fers
c'est lui qui sera tuée cette nuit
il a fermé la porte
[Musique]
on est là les allemands nous
encerclaient au stationnement
brillante des intérêts at me gratte
ils ont capturé tout l'équipage
tous ont été torturés
situé
[Musique]
je suis à l'avs réussi à m'enfuir il ne
court pas fait
j'ai mis la vie de personnes innocentes
en danger on vous attendait depuis un
petit moment
j'ai alors réalisé qu'il ne s'agissait
plus de mois rapporte tout ce qu'on a en
couverture et bardage
tu sais qui c'est il s'agissait de
quelque chose de beaucoup plus grand
vous appelez jan jan poels re tu la
verve d'être doué avec des cartes
tu peux me montrer où est la suite
[Musique]
c'est l'assiette c'est un long voyage
et
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
hahaha
vous
marie stuart et condamné à main sur
ordre de notre souveraine elizabeth
reine d'angleterre
comment en est on arrivé là
j'ai eu des nouvelles le roi françois et
main votre cousine marie est revenue
pour régner sur les casses c'est une
femme redoutable notamment
donc elle se prépare à la guerre pas du
tout certes je commande de désarmer mais
dit à ma cousine que nous prions pour
rester en tête
j'espère que nous nous rencontrerons
pour pouvoir sceller le destin
regarder la vérité en face madame c'est
une prétendante à votre trône
je devrai détrôné une reine kim et
apparentés une guerre civile éclatera
soit là bas soit ici un fléau s'est
abattue sur notre terre une femme qui
porte une couronne
kandé son frère son allégeance nous est
acquise
ils n'ont pas d'appétit pour la guerre
alors ouvrons leur l'appétit ce que les
armes sont créés j'essaye simplement de
faire l'unité de ce pays
mais ils veulent s'emparer de ma
couronne une meurtrière une traîtresse
et rennes mais je serai la femme qu'elle
n'est pas nous mettons au monde un
héritier au trône décosse et
d'angleterre
notre rencontre elle secrète
si vous en parlez je n'irai tous accepté
d'être la marraine de monfils accepté
d'être ma soeur
marie est notre ennemi
nous ne nous inclinerons pas devant elle
comme nous le faisons devant vous
vous ne pouvez pas lever une armée vous
doutez souvent de ce que je suis en
mesure de faire n'entrez pas dans leur
jeu votre coeur vaut mieux que les
hommes qui vous conseille vous devriez
mesurer vos propos je refuse de me faire
tancer par une intérieure puis
l'intérieur
[Musique]
si vous choisissiez de me tuer
couture et votre certes
et vous tuerez votre reine
comment en est on arrivé là
[Musique]
ancien ram passé comme ça la marque de
la voiture je peux tout à fait sûr mais
pour le reste quasiment plus un fort
[Musique]
soutien au brut s'est pas défilée
l'agent pouls pendant huit ans j'ai vécu
avec un sale type
un sale mais qu'un minable tu sais quoi
le pian il a bien dit innocent prison
je sache est bonne ça va va bien le gars
la fed a mis ce qu il a pris des cinq
ans louis c'est notre faute tout ça il
est perdu soucis physiques en football a
requis c'est quoi ce truc de massacrer
calmement les gens comme ça on n'avait
pas vraiment eu de battue on avait
l'impression du ranger son bureau ça
monsieur
pardon twitter parfait pendant six à
m'excuser j'ai fait 80 ans je suis
innocent j'ai droit de scalper
d'éviction trottoir non mais tu te rends
compte que c'est une règle de soulac
je suis désolé je pensais que ce n'était
pas tant parce que je suis encore très
bon
je le prends mon but est de connaître
s'il vous plaît avec du pain non réglés
qui est l établissement je m'y attendais
un peu plus ce souci où ils ont failli
un peu tard pardonnez moi je voulais pas
laisser les cuisines ouvertes vous
foutez moi l'un d'eux at heart a peu
goûté le fallait
[Musique]
d
bien sûr que je n'ai pas marre de gauche
vis de moi